اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ مع ما سمعناه
من أه جيك سوليفان وهو يقول إن إسرائيل
ستنتقل إلى ما أسماه
المرحلة الجديدة من الحرب ولكنه يدعو أيضًا
إلى مزيد من الاهتمام لتجنب سقوط
ضحايا من المدنيين رد فعلك على ما
سمعنا تعليقات السيد سوليفان
أنا  أعتقد أن ما يقوله السيد سوليفان
ليس كافياً على الإطلاق بل على
العكس فهو يدعو إلى
استمرار هذه الحرب الرهيبة
لأشهر قادمة أه إذا أحصينا
الفلسطينيين الذين قتلوا بما فيهم من هم
تحت الثوار الذي
تتحدث عنه ما لا يقل عن  25.000
قتيل فلسطيني و10.000 طفل
قتلوا، بالإضافة إلى 50.000
جريح، كم عدد الأشخاص الذين
يجب أن يموتوا؟ أعتقد أن الحل ليس
استمرار هذه الحرب الرهيبة
التي ستودي بحياة الفلسطينيين
والإسرائيليين على حد سواء، بل بوقف الحرب
منذ اليوم السابع.  في تشرين الأول/أكتوبر كنا
نقول إن الحل الأفضل هو
وقف إطلاق النار الدائم الكامل وتبادل
الأسرى اليوم كما
ذكرت، فالإسرائيليون يطلقون النار على
سجنائهم حتى الآن، ولم يقتصر الأمر على مقتل
آخر ثلاثة أشخاص، بل قُتل 19 آخرون بسبب
القصف الإسرائيلي و
وتشير التقديرات الآن إلى أن ما لا يقل عن 300 منهم
قتلوا أيضًا في 7 أكتوبر
من قبل الطائرات الإسرائيلية، والحل هو
وقف إطلاق النار الفوري والدائم
وليس استمرار هذه الحرب نعم،
وهذه النقطة الأخيرة تشير إلى
مشاهدينا والتي لم يسبق لها مثيل  تم التحقق من ذلك
أه وقد أبلغنا للتو بالطبع
عن الغضب المتزايد أيضًا من تل
أبيب لإعادة الرهائن إلى الوطن
بالطبع أه حيث يتطلع الجيش الإسرائيلي إلى
التحقيق كما تعلم قوات السيد باروتي
وايت عن طريق الخطأ هناك كلمات
قتلت ثلاثة أه رهائن إسرائيليين  اسمحوا لي أن
أتحدث إليكم عن السياسة لأنني
أعتقد وأود أن أحصل على
أفكاركم حول ما شهدناه هذا الأسبوع من
صدع متزايد بين الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل
فيما يتعلق بما يسمى باليوم الذي تلا
إعلان الولايات المتحدة عن فلسطين.
ينبغي على السلطات أن تتولى
مسؤوليات الحكم في غزة بعد الحرب،
لكن نتنياهو رفض الفكرة مرارا وتكرارا
قائلا إن ذلك لن يحدث
طالما أنه رئيس الوزراء. ما هي
التحديات التي يواجهها السيد باروتي، هل ترى هنا كيف تخيط
الولايات المتحدة هذه الإبرة بشكل
جيد؟ التحدي يكمن في
نتنياهو  الحكومة هي
حكومة متطرفة للغاية
وفيها عناصر فاشية مثل SM وBing
ونتنياهو نفسه مهتم بشيء
واحد فقط وهو استمرار هذه الحرب
إلى الأبد لأنه إذا فقد منصبه
كرئيس للوزراء فسوف يذهب إلى السجن
هذا أمر مؤكد أه  والحقيقة هنا هي
أن ما يتحدث عنه نتنياهو هو
إعادة احتلال غزة ومن ثم إيجاد
دولة أخرى أو
هيكل آخر لرعاية
الاحتياجات المدنية للأشخاص الذين يعيشون تحت احتلاله،
في انتهاك للقانون الدولي الذي
يقول الأمريكيون إنهم يريدونه.  جلب
السلطة الفلسطينية ولكن يجب
أن تكون سلطة من نوع مختلف.
لا أعرف أي نوع من السلطة،
أمن، تأمين المزيد من الأمن،
سلطة لن تنجح.
الواقع هو أنه لا يمكن لأحد أن يفرض على
الفلسطينيين من يجب أن يحكمهم، وهو ما
ينبغي أن يكون.  يتعين على الفلسطينيين المعياريين أن
يختاروا قادتهم من خلال
انتخابات ديمقراطية حرة
حرمنا منها منذ
عام 2006، لكن إعادة احتلال غزة لن يؤدي
إلا إلى تعقيد المشكلة. ما نحتاجه
هو إنهاء الاحتلال الموجود
هناك منذ 56 عامًا وعدم توسيعه إلى
غزة